-Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hey, before we get started,
everyone do me a favor.
Check under your seats for
any classified documents from
The White House.
They just seem to be
everywhere lately.
Yeah, everyone is
talking about this.
A second batch
of classified documents
were found at President Biden's
home in Delaware.
Good Lord. Apparently,
presidents lose
classified documents
the way we lose AirPods.
It's like...
It's getting crazy.
Now, instead of quarters,
Biden's finding classified
documents behind kids' ears.
It's like, "Oh, look at that.
The nuclear codes from Iran."
Yeah, most of the new documents
were found in Biden's garage.
Come on. These are the nation's
top secrets.
They should all be stored in
that crazy puzzle box from
"Knives Out 2."
"Aim it towards..."
Another classified document
was found in a room
that Biden calls
his personal library.
Oh, please. Just say bathroom.
You know? I mean...
The White House said it was just
a small number of
classified documents.
That's like your doctor saying,
"Don't worry.
It's just a smidge of herpes."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
"Barely -- barely...
Just an unch, just an unch."
This morning,
Biden addressed the discovery
of the second batch
of documents,
and here's what he said.
-People know I
take classified documents
and classified materials
seriously.
[ Laughter ]
-Here's how Fox News aired it.
-People know I take
classified documents.
♪♪
-There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Interesting.
But the Justice Department is
taking this seriously.
Today, the attorney general
appointed a special counsel
to investigate Biden's
handling of the documents.
Yeah. I'm not saying
Biden's getting worried,
but he just texted
Rudy Giuliani.
So, you go, "Wow!
That's not good.
That's not good."
That's right -- they appointed
a special counsel.
Biden tried to spin it.
He said, "Good news --
I'm creating jobs."
But The White House
is now saying that
they are confident
an investigation will show
the documents were
inadvertently misplaced.
Next, he'll be like,
"I was just holding it for
a friend, I swear."
Switching gears, I saw that
Prince Harry's memoir, "Spare,"
is breaking sales records.
It is massive.
And this is very interesting --
his book deal
includes three more books.
So he's already working
on sequels.
In fact, we got our hands on
some of the titles
that he's considering.
-Oh, here we go.
-What's up, Tariq?
-Let me guess.
You're going to poke fun
at Prince Harry
by listing a bunch of
fake book titles.
-I mean, yeah,
that was the plan.
-I know exactly
how this will go down.
So, you'll show a graphic
with a picture of Prince Harry
that says, "New Book Titles."
And then, under that, you'll
list a bunch of jokes like...
Or...
-Yeah, yeah, maybe.
-Or...
And then you'll do...
-Yeah.
-Or...
-Uh-huh.
-And then...
-Yeah.
-Or...
-That's right.
-Then, finally,
you'll just do...
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Is that how
it's going to go, Jimmy?
-Uh, yeah, you nailed it.
-It's a fun bit.
You should do it on the show.
-Well, maybe some other time.
Got some TV news.
"Wheel of Fortune" was just
renewed for five more seasons,
and the deal includes
a big raise for Pat Sajak.
You can tell Pat's excited.
Check out
one of today's puzzles.
-I'll take a "C."
-Yeah, that's it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Come on! What --
-Wow! Don't rub it in.
-Did you guys see this?
I heard that Subway might be
sold for more than $10 billion.
Yeah, the sale could be done
in a few months
or a little longer if they want
their Subway toasted.
And, finally, after being closed
for years due to COVID,
the public bathrooms in several
New York City subway
stations were just reopened.
-Whoo-hoo!
-Yeah.
And you're not going to
believe this.
When they opened them up, they
found more classified documents.
-What?!